so uh looking at your resume here it's
it's looking great uh you're really
you're really quite overqualified for
the job which is great there's uh just a
couple things I want to go over before
we you know say welcome aboard uh Hank
uh that's your name right Hank yeah yeah
um one of the things is uh you know this
is an 8 hour work day it's 8 hours
straight we do take about 30 minutes for
lunch MH but uh pretty much it's going
to be straight through is that going to
be a problem for you no no we don't
really
uh we don't really you know take uh take
too many
naps
here there's not really like a an
allotted nap time you know for for
curling up curling up in maybe the Sun
and taking a little nap uh it's going to
be pretty much straight through so is
that that's fine is that going to be a
problem it's fine oh that's it's good
it's good to hear that is good it's good
to hear yeah um restrooms there's uh
there's roughly four or five restrooms
per per floor mhm um is that going to
be is that going to be okay for you yeah
because um because basically we uh we
just have the regular bathrooms just
urinals and the regular stall
toilets if
you if you went to the bathroom you
would you use that or would you
absolutely yeah you wouldn't uh you
wouldn't cover your waist with the tiny
Stones small Pebbles so we don't have
that
here if that's not a problem that's it's
not no okay great okay okay
great that is very good to hear good
okay
do you know
Excel